President Trump is trying to reassure
conservatives that he's not breaking a
campaign promise to crack down on
illegal immigration in a letter to his
supporters the president said quote we
will build a wall not a fence along the
southern border of the United States of
America to help stop illegal immigration
and keep America safe this comes after
he made a tentative agreement with
Democrats that would push the border
wall to bet to the backburner Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning the president went
back and forth on Thursday at some
points insisting there is no agreement
and at others saying that everyone's on
board he seems to be trying to do the
impossible secure and easy bipartisan
win without angering the base president
Trump promised supporters Thursday he
isn't going soft on immigration we're
not looking at citizenship we're not
looking at allowing but Democratic
leaders said that mr. Trump agreed over
dinner to back the DREAM Act a bill that
would give young undocumented immigrants
a potential path to citizenship it's a
long path moves like a fifteen-year pet
and this is an earned pet in the DREAM
Act it's about serving in the military
Orbach being employed or being in school
for a period of time we're having the
conversations with our members right now
which is why House Speaker Paul Ryan
incision we the first day nothing has
been decided have you asked the
President to at least check with you
before the agreement first of all there
is no agreement these were discussions
not negotiations there isn't an
agreement both sides say any agreement
will have to include more border
security Democrats proposed additional
funding for drones air support sensor
equipment and for rebuilding roads along
the border Senate Republicans seem open
to I like the fact of the president's
getting people to talk it's the only way
you produce an outcome a lot of people
want to
but even Democrats are surprised at the
president's new outreach Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer was overheard saying this
on the Senate floor he likes us that's
me and privately many Republicans are
actually happy to leave this particular
negotiation to the president because
Dale it takes some of the heat off of
them on what can be a sticky issue for
some of their voters Nancy Cordes I have
to say we all took a little chuckle in
the studio with your question to Paul
Ryan even Paul Ryan had to figure out
how to hold his face on three nicely
done thank you very much Nancy Cordes